rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message love
your customers
over to you Tony Robbins treat people at
the end of the relationship like it's
the beginning and it won't be an end and
that's not just your intimate
relationship what if your customers what
if you fell in love with your customers
with your clients more than your product
more than your company if your entire
life was about meeting their needs if
you would do what for your customers
clients you would do what if you loved
your customers and clients you'd do
anything
guess what they're gonna love you but
most people love their customers and
clients as long as they buy from them do
what they want respond to them and then
they don't they go that's the end you
want clients for life not just customers
fall in love with them it's a different
focus isn't it it's a different meaning
and that creates a different life
because you make decisions differently
from that place too many people treat
their business like a machine that's
supposed to just generate money for them
instead of understanding what a business
actually is and that's when you provide
a lot of value to your customers then
guess what they come back they want to
find more they tell their friends when
you love them when you treat them like
they're your family like they're the
closest thing to you when they feel that
love and care and attention then they
love you back you have to give it first
before you can expect to receive it most
people are used to being treated like a
number it's why do you stand out as an
entrepreneur it's gonna come because you
your store your passion will come
through instead of dealing with a giant
corporation the benefit of going with a
big company is they have the reputation
they have the experience they have the
trust they have the customers they have
the testimonials why should I buy from
you instead of buying from this big
giant corporation because you're gonna
care right because I love you because I
see your stock and I'm just consumed by
it because you're storing means
something to me
because you're gonna try to help me out
when that big company isn't that's how
you win as an entrepreneur especially in
the early stages you need your customers
to love you and that's not gonna come
from them loving you first it's gotta be
the other way around you have to love
them first you have to
ever deliver like crazy you have to give
them more than what they expected a
couple quick examples from my life my
real estate agent this guy was just the
closest guy to me when I was looking to
get a new condo and sell my house this
guy was the closest guy to me he was
across the street like oh yeah great
that guy great literally you know
accidental coming across this guy and he
did a fantastic job not just helping me
in terms of the advice and how much
should I sell for and managing the
process but a lot of it of managing me
and what I hate so you know I hate
paperwork I hate it like seeing a real
estate signing all the papers I hate it
I hate it I hate it it's such a waste of
time I hate formalities and
administrative work and so he allowed me
to do everything electronically it's
great paste
yes accept accept accept done automatic
signature yes amazing right I love it
and that's kind of a little bit beyond
the expectation right compared to other
real estate agents it's not it's not
like amazing but it's better than what
most people would do but the next one
you know I had a leak in my fridge I had
a leak in the freezer no like I wanted I
kept coming out onto my floor and I
didn't know how to solve it you know I'm
not a I'm the least handy guy in the
world I could change a lightbulb but
that's a button I didn't know why this
thing kept leaking and I had to keep
cleaning up the floor so Marc came over
he said you know what let me come over
I'll just come over and check it out
like yeah you can we could deal with the
building and all that stuff but let me
just come over and see and he came over
and he showed me the problem he said
here's how you fix it right like he took
time out of his evening after you'd
already closed the sale and like the
next time I'm gonna buy from him and
move out to another place maybe a couple
years so why invest the time right he
already done a great job for me I was
still gonna refer him and probably work
with him the next time why invest the
time to come over it's just that's his
style and I love it right I love it and
so the next time I move I'm hiring him
again anybody who asked me for a real
estate agent I'm giving him the business
and you got a deal with Marc first he's
gonna give you amazing service and just
by doing those little extra things by
him showing me love I'm gonna chew that
back to him that seems to do for your
business there's another woman named
Marie
I'm doing some some work with now she
was the she's the mother of someone who
works for me at my business and she was
selling Internet services like okay
great like try to support the people in
my community in my you know my my family
of employees and I thought okay great
we'll use that service and the service
didn't end up really working out for us
just for a variety of reasons didn't
quite provide the level that we needed
but I loved her you know I met her and
she's got this just insane vibe amazing
energy trying to contribute asking me
about my business trying to figure out
ways to help even though she's not in my
business you know she doesn't know
anything about my business she's not the
expert in my business but she just loves
it right when I had my book come out as
soon as I posted on Facebook to my
friends I need people to review my book
anybody wants to review my book I need
feedback any 30 people she's like one of
the first ones in I want to read the
book I want to give feedback and she
devoured it left amazing feedback
underlining highlights mistakes
suggestions and just had this amazing
caring giving vibe and so after the
internet thing she switched businesses
to another company selling a whole bunch
of natural products I don't remember the
name I can't pronounce names it's crazy
name and I'm now looking for ways to
help her right so the deal we worked out
as part of that business sells
nutritional bars energy bars healthy
energy bars it's like great I want to
help you I love you every month I want
to order a hundred dollars worth of
energy bars and will give them to my
team at Toronto vein salsa do I need
them not really what I have done it
normally no I just love Maria she's
great like she did so much to help me
from just a love energy great person to
be around so much care that now I'm
going out of my way to try to help her
and find ways that I can help her in her
business that's what you want that's
what you need you got to show so much
insane love towards your customers that
they feel it you break through you're
the one company that breaks through that
actually cares about that person and
then it'll come back to you they will
buy from you they will look for reasons
to want to buy from you they'll look for
reasons to want to refer people on to
you because they felt that love that you
showed them stop treating your business
like it's just an income
machine it actually care about your
customer and you do that you start to
see a big growth so the question today
today is I'm curious what is something
that you've done to really show the love
to a customer what's the story you're
most proud of of what you did to help a
customer out leaving the comments below
really curious to find that I also want
to give a quick shout out to William
Intune from Project authenticity org
thank you so much or pick up a copy of
my book your one-word and posting that
picture in that blog post of you going
through the exercise I really appreciate
it I hope you gained a lot from the book
and are applying the lessons to your
life in your business and I just want to
thank you for your support so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
and I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events best
do you care what people say what people
think no I mean I gave up a long long
time worrying and concerning myself over
that you know I care what people say
about what I do professionally I care
about what my customer says you know
that that's what I do care about because
why do I do what I do I do what I do
because I love women I want to empower
women I want women to feel good I want
them to feel beautiful and so I care
about what what my customer thinks
because I want to give her what she
wants but generally speaking I don't I
don't focus too much on anything
negative brands are so important and
that's one thing at the company we're
making a big investment in of building
our brands but building it based on
substance starting with having great
cars trucks and crossovers starting with
having a good relationship when you
interact with the company when you
interact with our dealers because
they're there our face of the company
and it's it's it's every one of the
things in our value of customer is every
interaction matters and if you really
put the customer at the center and you
look at because what I find with most
customers I mean we you know a car truck
or crossover has about 3,000 parts that
are integrated with millions and
millions of lines of software and we
have rigorous validation processes and
and they're improving as we really you
know work to be industry leaders and
having a systems approach to how we put
cars in the road on the road but if
something happens a customer a wants you
to care once it wants you to listen
wants you to care and would like you to
fix it and it's really that easy if you
listen you care and you fix it they will
be your you know your best advocate one
of the stories I tell is in the early
days of the ignition switch one of the
things we said we had done extensive
testing we knew the vehicles were safe
to drive if you just use the key or a
key with just a ring but we said to him
to customers if you are uncomfortable we
will give you a loaner and so in the
early days you know getting that
situated we're communicating to all of
our dealers making sure they knew and
getting the loaners I had a customer who
was very upset said you know you you
said I could I could get a loaner I went
to my
dealer they said they don't have one you
know and and so he sent me a note saying
you know I it was and it was kind of
personal it's like and I hate you and
I'm never gonna buy a General Motors
product again it wasn't exactly that but
that was the tone and and so I said it
was of course it was on a Friday
afternoon and I went okay and so I
called my head of customer service week
you know and I sent the note I sent a
note back to him because they other than
email I didn't know how to get ahold of
my said could I could I call you would
you would you be willing to share your
phone number and could I give you a call
so minute or two later I get the phone
number I pick up the phone I call him I
listen and I said you know what you know
this is it's early days and getting
loaners I'm sure there was a
misunderstanding would you give me a
chance to work on this and I immediately
called Alicia Bullard Davis our head of
customer care at that time and by the
next morning we had a car for him and
the next week I got this note I can't
believe you cared I can't believe he
talked to me and I can't believe the
next day I had a I had a loaner and so
and you know said this is you know this
is a company I wanted to be want to be
associated with and so again it's every
interaction does matter and I think
doing the right things you know putting
technological technologically leading
vehicles and services and providing that
value to customers but then if something
happens dealing with it and standing up
I think that's the only way right now
would be the perfect time to share a
customer service story with you true
story a couple years ago I got a call
from a young lady and it's all excited
she tells me she's looking for a
property and then she says the word
lease our favorite words as Realtors I'm
looking for a lease uh you know unless
it's an eighty five thousand dollar a
month lease oh well but I was in a good
mood so I took that call and I said sure
I'll help you find a lease and turns out
it was a five thousand dollar month
lease and I took her around
for six months the term was only a year
anyways I like to finish what I start so
I went through with it found her an
amazing place she couldn't be happier in
fact she was so happy that she called
her father that night and she said dad I
got the greatest place my realtor is
amazing he doesn't care about money at
all and it happened to be that her
father was sitting next to the CEO of
his company and he heard the story and
that CEO said actually I'm thinking
selling my penthouse maybe I should use
that guy sure enough I went in I met the
CEO and I got the listing of his four
million dollar penthouse while I was
sitting that open house on that four
million dollar penthouse cuz that's my
favorite thing to do a celebrity walked
in and that celebrity walked around and
he checked out that incredible penthouse
and he looked me it looked at me and he
said yeah this is cool do you have
anything cooler I said sure
so I went back to the office and I put
together the list of the coolest
penthouses you could find and I showed
that celebrity around and that celebrity
ended up buying an 11 million dollar
penthouse which broke the record for
Santa Monica so from that lease that
$5,000 a month lease which led to that
four million dollar penthouse sale which
led to that 11 million dollar penthouse
sale and it is the gift that keeps on
giving
on and on and on that is why customer
service is so important to everybody's
business raise your standard Apple cool
it's core value is that we believe that
people with passion can change the way
people not one drop of myself work
depends on your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details